I have these three star patches I guess
you could call them right over here and
so I could say if I had one group of
three star patches how many star patches
do I have so I literally have one group
of three star patches well that means
that I have three star patches one two
three this is my one group of three now
let's make a little bit more interesting
let's say that I had two groups let's
say that I had two groups of three so
that's one group and then here's the
second group here's two groups of three
so how many total star patches do I have
now well I have two groups of three two
groups of three or another way of
thinking about is this is three plus
three
this is equal to three plus three which
is equal to six equal to six
so we see one times three one group of
three is three two groups of three which
is literally two threes is six let's
make it even more interesting let's have
three groups of three three groups of
three now what is this going to be equal
to what's three groups of three so I
could write this as three groups three
times three and how many of these star
patches do I now have well this is going
to be 3 plus 3 plus 3 it's going to be 3
plus 3 plus 3 notice I have three threes
I have two threes I have one three so
this is 3 plus 3 plus 3 is equal to is
equal to 9 and you can count them one
two three four five six seven eight nine
or you could just count by threes three
six nine and I think you see where this
is going let's keep incrementing it
let's get four groups of three so let's
think about what four times three is one
two three and four
this right over here is four groups of
three we could write this down as four
times three four times three
which is the same thing which is the
same thing as 3 plus 3 plus 3 plus 3 3
plus 3 plus 3 plus 3 notice I have four
threes one three two threes three threes
four threes 1 3 2 threes three threes
four threes so we get 3 6 9 12 12 so
what I encourage you to do now now that
the video is almost over is to keep
going I want you to figure out what 5
times 3 is 5 times 3 and 6 times 3 and 7
times 3 and 8 times 3 and 9 9 times 3
and 10 times 3 and I'll give you a
little hint you don't always have to
draw the star patches but it's nice to
visualize it we saw 4 times 3 is only
four threes well 5 times 3 is going to
be 5 threes so 2 3 4 5 5 which is equal
to 3 6 9 12 15 15 so I encourage you to
think about what all of these are after
this video is done